I've heard a rumor Daniel Dwyer and you
can correct me if I'm wrong but I
understand that you've just had the
privilege of seeing a new FIFA game yes
in the 15 fifa game 50 FIFA 15 and I
know Sean McKenna's who doesn't play
fifa games you probably want me to talk
to you about it in really vague terms
yes unfortunately you can't do it i
would beef up nope but I happy it's all
ball physics me riding Borg of specific
things to say about FIFA 15 I'm just
gonna go for it let's get into her way
to so first things first formation
screen has changed [ __ ] yes people's
faces players faces are there it's not
like the usual one that's been there
since 2008 it's different it'll be scary
at first but trust me it's marginally
better the presentation is much sharper
it looks like television they did this
like high contrast thing cameras shake
sometimes like the cameraman [ __ ] it
up alright he's like a little bit drunk
yeah which is what happens a lot because
those ports you know when you pause the
game it goes into like a shows you some
highlights and stuff it's pretty good
commentary is good even have photographs
for the commentators when it comes up
it's pretty great and they do this thing
will talk about the fans and the camera
were like actually cut to the fans so
all in all it's a lot more like
television II okay and I like that I
appreciate it but a parfait it's the
little things it's the little things
there are a lot of little things attack
and defend you could usually on the
d-pad say you wanted to go normal McVey
lence or a hacker defend or ultra attack
or ultra the potent offense now you can
go ultra ultra attack and ultra altered
avenge specifically ultra ultra attack
is called everyone up front or something
like that yeah balls out what
let's go balls out Stefan enough sorry
but the defend one is absolutely called
park the bus oh that you can just go
back to that spark the boss article bus
while you players just go back into the
box it's brilliant that's exact time
goalkeepers were being really weird but
I with the players when the balls came
back they were like freaking out I'm
hoping the game isn't finished because
if that would be kind of dumb if it was
in the fertile and the full one hide it
to the fans trapping the ball like when
you're actually like trying to get the
ball up somebody it's a lot easier in
this one that was in the last next-gen
won the last current gen 1 to get the
ball off the player sounds great music's
great college grades atmospheres grace
same as the last game there's a
goal-kick option when you're the goalie
you can hit like the right trigger and
you can tell your players to go out cuz
you're not gonna do short pass I got
this guy with free kicks there is as
well you can choose to become the player
and one of the receivers and then you
can ask for like a high ball or a low
ball I bet yours I ask for those locals
no no right here I'm saying say that's
our third ball joke of this same a
corner kicks as well by the way I have
another ball Joe oh do you okay well I'm
sure I can cram one in before we finish
this I'm in corner kicks as well if
you're taking a corner you can that seem
like tactical dial in the deep as you
can go like front post cried the
goalkeeper stuff like that so
yeah and that's my long list of FIFA
stuff done and dusted oh the one more
thing they've also changed it and
they've added a number so it's 15
instead of 14 14 leave one pattern one
better FIFA 15 you got any questions
about my balls yeah why are they so
weird looking for more coverage from
gamescom 2014 stay tuned to gamespot com
but seriously they're real gross
you